he had no idea  I hate great handsome funny a powerful  and he's got that beautiful bald head I  mean I have hair but it's thinning on  top and I don't have the guts to shave  it all off because I don't know if it'll  look good what in the name of God do I  do  introducing the power dome the quickest  easiest way to become a confident bald  man without actually losing your hair  Wow how are you Scott Ritter CEO why yes  I am  Ed Harris you're fired you're fired  you're fired  I just had sex in the supply closet  finally if you have a mom and dad call  them on the phone don't text them  timeout rep timeout sorry babe  while your neighbors with your new look  it was pitbull  power dome gets you a head impress your  co-workers and let Greg know who's boss  [Music]  hey don't need to do that  Oh  [Music]  I don't begin to understand what that  was all about  [Laughter]  you